what I hope to do in this video is
explore the relationship between oil and
gas prices and you do see that there is
a very strong correlation between how
they trend this right over here is oil
prices quoted at a specific point on the
planet it is dependent on where you are
as you can see this is in US dollars per
barrel early 2008 around a hundred
dollars went up to 140 then came back
down and then it's been trending up ever
since now it's about a hundred dollars
per barrel this is where we see the the
oil prices on a per barrel basis and
then related to that you see the price
of gasoline and this is even more
geographically specific because not only
do you have transportation cost but you
also have very very region specific
taxation for oil and sometimes
regulation but taxation is the big part
of it but you do see it trends up when
oil prices trend up and then it goes
down and this is on a per gallon basis
and these are the prices right over here
in New York but they don't move
completely lockstep if anything you see
that the oil price on a per barrel basis
is much more volatile than the gasoline
price it right over here but there is
the same general trend when the oil
prices moves up this tends to move up
but it's not always in the same
percentage but there's definitely a
relationship now before trying to figure
out when you pay say four dollars at the
pump how much of that is oil and how
much is refining and how much is
transportation let's at least kind of
build up to that to think about just how
does the oil even end up in your in your
car and then we can build up that price
of the oil so the or the price of the
gasoline I should say so this right over
here you are probably familiar with
these these are oil rigs two very
different types this is an offshore oil
rig this is a land-based oil rig but
they're both doing the same fundamental
thing they're drilling into the ground
until they get to a pocket of oil and
then they will pump that oil out and try
to transport it to the market somehow
first going through a refinery offshore
is really fascinating it really is an
engineering marvel how they do it it
might be sitting out here in the ocean
and it will literally go to the bottom
of the ocean go to the sea floor and
then drill from there to actually get to
the oil pockets so it's really an
engineering marvel
have to be very careful it can be very
dangerous working on oil rig and
obviously if there's an accident on them
it can be an environmental nightmare
like what we saw with the BP situation
but it is undoubtedly an engineering
marvel now once you have that oil you
need to get it to a refinery so that
that oil can be broken up into its
useful parts and the way that is
typically transported to a refinery is
some combination of a pipeline or an oil
tanker this right over here is actually
the Alaskan the Alaskan pipeline and it
takes oil from the very northern part of
Alaska to the southern part so that it
can then be put on oil tankers which can
then transport it anywhere in the world
to refineries it could go straight to a
tanker actually even some offshore
places you could use a tank or sometimes
they even if they're close enough to
land they actually might have a pipeline
that will take it to land where it can
go to a refinery or go to an oil tanker
so to be transported even farther and
then from there it gets to a refinery
and so we can start to think about how
the price of oil is built up before we
even think about what a refinery even
does so let's say let's say that the the
current price of oil and I kind of
rigged the numbers not to be not to be
too punny to work out fairly well but
let's say that the current price of oil
is ninety dollars per barrel $90 $90 per
per barrel so a barrel is equal and this
is just a unit's thing this is a barrel
is equal to 42 gallons so if I say I
have a gap a barrel of water I'm really
saying that I have 42 gallons of water
and now all 42 gallons of crude oil do
not turn into 42 gallons of gasoline out
of 42 gallons of crude oil you can get
about 19 or 20 gallons of gasoline for
the sake of to make the numbers easy
I'll just go 20 20 gallons of gasoline
gasoline and then the rest will be other
stuff the rest is other stuff so 22
gallons of other stuff and it might not
even be 22 gallons effective won't be
some of it is just waste some of its
byproducts some of this is actually used
to fuel the refining process so I won't
let me right now
right that numbers so the rest is other
stuff other other stuff so let's say
let's say so this refinery is paying $90
per barrel when it gets it so that
incorporates what the what the oil
producers are getting it also takes care
of the transportation costs to the
refinery and let's say just for the sake
of argument that the refinery the
refinery can sell when let's say it
doesn't even take care of the
transportation network let's say there's
people who are willing to buy directly
from the refinery at the refinery they
were willing to buy gasoline at 3
dollars 25 per gallon so there so the
gas at refinery
so at refinery at refinery
people are willing to spend or the
transporter is willing to pay them three
dollars three dollars and 25 cents per
gallon and so from this from this barrel
20 they're going to get 20 gallons of
gasoline they can sell that at 3 dollars
25 per gallon so you're going to have
you're going to have 20 times 3.25 which
is 2 C 20 times 3 is 60 and then 20
times twenty five cents is five dollars
so they're going to get sixty five
dollars for the gasoline for the
gasoline and then let's just say for the
sake of argument they get thirty five
dollars for the other stuff they get
thirty five dollars for the other stuff
and some of this other stuff is quite
useful it's stuff like motor oil it
could be jet fuel it could be natural
gas all sorts of all and it could be
obviously fuel to actually fuel the
refinery and so let's actually start
building up building this up right over
here so so one way to think about it one
way to think about it so let me draw it
this way so the price so we're up to 325
per gallon is what the price is exiting
the refinery what the refinery is
getting for it so let me draw it down
here so let me draw a let me draw it
like this so let's say that this is one
dollar this is two dollars and this is
three dollars
and then they're getting $3.25 $3.25
would be like that that is what the
refinery is getting and one way to think
about it it's not completely because all
of all of their profit isn't coming from
the gasoline but one way to think about
it is the refinery after refining all
this this bet this barrel of crude oil
that they paid $90 for they're going to
get $65 for the gasoline and then
they're going to get $35 they're going
to get $35 for the actual for the other
stuff so they made a combination of what
is it they made $100 they're able to buy
this crude oil at $90 do what they had
to do and then they're able to sell it
for $100 so one way to think about is
that at least in this situation 90
percent of what they're getting for it
was their cost but it's kind of its kind
of it breaks down between the other
stuff in the gasoline so it's not super
easy to break down but you can say in
this example a good chunk of this was
the cost of gasoline a good chunk and
it's obviously depends how you count for
it but a good chunk of it not the cost
of gasoline a good chunk of it is the
cost of the crude and this right over
here you could say is how much the
refinery actually makes and that the the
amount that the refinery gets versus
what it costs so the amount they get for
all of the products they produce versus
the crude oil that they have to pay for
this margin this is often called the
crack spread this is called the crack
spread and just to understand what a
refinery is doing it's breaking up that
crude oil into its various parts and
it's actually a fairly simple but I
don't want to say simple process
obviously when you look at a refinery
does not look like a simple thing but
the idea for the process is fairly
straightforward
it takes the crude oil so it takes the
crude and it heats it up through a
boiler it heats it up through a boiler
so right over here the crude is getting
really hot this is the boiler and the
boiler is fueled often fueled are
usually fueled by some of the outputs of
that oil so this is fire right you just
to symbolize that it's getting hot and
then it goes into a distillation column
and the distillation column that's why
you see all of these towers right over
here in an oil refinery those are the
distillation columns and so in a
distillation columns
the different parts of the oil have
different boiling temperatures so the
very long carbon change in the oil have
very high boiling temperatures so as hot
as they are they're not going to boil
they're going to stay in their liquid
form down here and then the slightly
shorter change they're going to they're
going to boil and evaporate a little bit
but then as they rise they're going to
cool down and then they might condense
right over here then they can be pulled
away in pipes and then things that are
even slightly shorter chains than that
will have will go a little bit higher
before cooling to even lower
temperatures before going back into a
liquid state and then they can be
collected over here all the way until
you get to the very shortest chains like
the natural gas that would be collected
out at the top and the gasoline that you
put in your car it might be collected
right over here might be collected right
over here from this so you're
essentially you're breaking up that oil
into its different parts and some of the
other parts this might be motor oil
right over here the thing that you use
to lubricate your engine not fuel your
engine you might have jet fuel up here
and you have a whole ton of other
different you know kerosene all sorts of
things you are able to take out of that
crude oil but anyway let's get back to
the gasoline so the refinery you got 325
now we have to transport that gasoline
so let's say $0.10 for transportation so
this is at 325 right over here so now
we're going to have 10 cents for
transportation so that right over here
is 10 cents for transportation train
I'll just write transportation for short
and then it goes to the gas station and
as I mentioned gas is heavily heavily
taxed and it depends on what
jurisdiction what country what and even
states within countries but for the sake
of simplicity let's just say it's taxed
at 50 cents a gallon which is not that
different from what is taxed at it in
many states so now we're at 50 cents a
gallon so that would be right around so
let's say let me do it a new color I
keep using the same colors over and over
again so let's say this is so then it's
50 cents a gallon tax so that is tax
right over there going to the going to
the state and federal government and so
let's see 325 is what the refinery got
$0.10 for transportation gets it's a 335
$0.50 tax so this is $0.50 tax
gets us to 385 385 and then now we're at
the gas station there essentially is
going to cost 385 a gallon for that fuel
the gas station needs to make some money
to pay their costs the gas station sells
you that fuel at $4 a gallon at $4 a
gallon and so you might say okay the gas
station and that already seems
surprisingly low and that is actually on
the order of how much gas stations
actually make on a per gallon basis you
might say hey the gas station made
fifteen cents four dollars - the 385
that takes in all of these other crap
core all of these other costs but
actually a huge amount of that fifteen
cents actually goes to the credit card
processors because most people pay at
the pump with a credit card and that's
why some gas stations like it will give
you a discount if you pay in cash
because of that fifteen cents as much as
and or in general around five cents of
that will go to the credit cards will go
to the credit card processors credit
card fees credit analyst is getting
messy credit card credit card fees so
the retailer will be left with about 10
cents will be left with 10 cents of
margin so anyway hopefully that gives
you a sense of how crude oil turns into
gasoline and if you when you pay at the
pump what is the breakdown for the
different players and how much of the
money is going to different to those
different players